un arresto considerado un golpe contra
la libertad de prensa en guatemala
estuvieron en la casa unas 45 horas
celular
en la noche del viernes el periodista
josé rubén zamora fue detenido por las
autoridades guatemaltecas en medio de un
proceso por presunto lavado de dinero
crítico con el gobierno de alejandro
giammatei el comunicador ya había
anunciado que el gobierno estaba
fabricando un caso para encarcelarle
este sábado zamora se declaró en huelga
de hambre y denunció su captura como una
conspiración y un caso de persecución
política para los defensores de derechos
humanos la detención del periodista
supone una alarma más contra las
libertades en la nación centroamericana
este contexto es alarmante ya
a su personal defensa ante sus clientes
son los más vulnerables actualmente no
lo digo sólo yo compro para derechos
humanos lo hizo también la ch
en su informe parlamento europeo el
departamento estaba estado sus niños
entonces estamos de alerta pues es
importante que dos guatemaltecos y
deponiendo internacional pues estemos
atento a cómo se desarrollan horas más
tarde en entrevista con la agencia afp
el procurador de los derechos humanos
alarmó que la situación de los derechos
en guatemala es cada vez más parecida a
la de nicaragua
a ser fatalistas la que no tenga boca de
profeta pero pienso que podemos estar
como una nicaragua con un daniel ortega
que se empodera quien participa no
criminalizar a los opositores y todo eso
entonces tenemos que estar muy
expectantes de rubén zamora lleva tiempo
denunciando que el gobierno deja mate y
tenga en sus filas a personas señaladas
de ser corruptas por parte de eeuu tras
su detención el reportero continúa a la
espera de que el juez dirima su
situación judicial